en fait et des petits trucs que les gens
font quand il téléphone qui me stresse
par exemple les gens qui prennent pas la
même voix dans la vraie vie et au
téléphone matteo combien de fois je vais
te dire de range ta [ __ ] de chambre
bordel de merde où il ya les bons jours
j'aime prendre rendez vous avec ma
bancaire s'il vous plaît isabelle
pistouille merci ce mec qui t'appelle
mais tu as l'impression que c'est toi
qui le dérange allô allô ça va ouais et
coutumes pas tout le temps lâché un peu
dans le rush on se rappelle un peu plus
tard ok ou alors les gens qui parlent
pendant un siècle
impossible de les stopper alors toi pour
amorcer leur accrochage tu lâches des
petits allaient y est d'accord on fait
comme ça ta gueule ta gueule maintenant
tard et de parler voilà je t'aime le mec
qui sur son fun quand tu l'appelles et
qui du coup décroche super vite il n'y a
même pas de bip alors anthony contrées
pour décrocher si vite car je te suis
depuis toujours
rivages et pas peur je sais que c'est
moi en fait ça ne fait spécial hagard up
des fois au téléphone quand tu
raccroches chacun a ses petites toques
tu vois ses petites manies
par exemple il ya ceux qui se mettent à
chuchoter pour dire au revoir
ok on fait comme ça a dit à demain ciao
qui fait une guerre depuis des fois tu
as des petits réflexes en accrochant que
tu regrettes après merci bisous
[Musique]
le patron ouais j'ai raccroché en disant
bisous mais c'est parce que je voulais
dire c'est d'accord je suis pas troubles
m merci à demain bisous les gens qui te
disent bonjour mais via quelqu'un
d'autre au téléphone ça donne le
dialogue le plus nul du monde
bah il est là attendu jeudi sylvie te
dis bonjour bad et lui bonjour de ma
part ils te répondent bonjour elle te
demande si ça va a dit quoi penser à moi
directement parce que là c'est super
chiant fait quand quelqu'un se trompe de
numéro et il n'arrive pas à comprendre
qui s'est trompé à l'eau jacqueline ah
non c'est pau jacqueline je pense que
vous avez composé un mauvais numéro là
elle est où jacqueline et je ne sais pas
où aller puisque c'est un mauvais numéro
donc je n'ai pas de rapports avec
jacqueline et ce qui est génial c'est
que là souvent le mec au bout de deux
minutes recompose le même mauvais numéro
alors jacqueline c'est ça c'est
jacqueline ouais tu passes une bonne
journée tu t'es chez du commun de poids
aujourd'hui quand on est au téléphone je
sais pas pourquoi on fait plein de trucs
un peu débile déjà quand ça capte mal
on dirait que les deux personnels font
une battle de bar de réseaux a loupé un
mec tu captes pas là moi j'ai deux
barres de réseaux a alors ça ça
m'étonnerait parce que la gt3 barre de
réseaux donc eh ben moi je chez bouygues
et sac à tout le temps normalement donc
c'est vraiment toi c'est sûr ah ouais
bah moi j'ai moi j'ai pas une petite
[ __ ] désolé j'avais pas d'arguments bien
sûr la fameuse technique ne pas
décrocher tout de suite pour faire style
tu es occupé
[Musique]
yes j'arrive taïga allô allô
moi j'avoue au téléphone comme la
personne ne me voit pas j'ai toujours
tenté de m'en tire un peu à lowell
franchement là je suis dans la rue
j'arrive à huawei c'est une rue sans
voiture essence en passant avec mon chat
qui miaule quand tu rappelles un numéro
que tu connais pas et la personne n'ose
pas dire qu'ils allaient alors qu'elle
vient de t'appeler c'est tellement
absurde
oui bonjour je me vais appeler omc qui
abat non c'est vous qui m'appelait donc
toi tu es qui n'entend t qui d'abord non
mais je dis pas toi t'es dit ok moi
c'est adolf hitler à comment il va quand
tu téléphones et que tout à coup tu te
mets en marche et nerveusement partout
chez toi ouais d'accord c'est pas vrai
ah les inquiète pas j'ai deux secondes
je vois un peu tôt parce que j'en peux
plus j'ai fait des kilomètres et je peux
pas finir sans parler des répondeurs
j'en ai marre d'entendre tout le temps
le même genre de répondeur bonjour vous
êtes bien sur le téléphone de pierre
nicolas
vous pouvez me laisser un message après
le bible je dis exactement ce qu'il faut
dire sur un message répondeur.allo et
non tu es sur mon répondeur thibout
blanchard bonjour je suis en déplacement
pro à new york
arrivé du ter à roubaix ah merde je me
raccroche
bonjour laissez-moi message après le bip
est là où l'ennemi un message à cette
bible je vous rappelle que je possède de
teufen d'être mieux manier aux attaques
garrett stafford bim bam
bonjour vous êtes bien sur le répondeur
des nordmann merci de vous abonner après
le bip sonore merci aussi d'avoir
orioles cette vidéo j'espère que vous a
plu et on se retrouve j'espère après le
cap des 10 millions d'abonnés youtube
yahoo
[Musique]